I can't make it clean if I put it on.
It's better.
I don't do anything beautiful.
[Music]
Next is ah.
Nothing
starts from 3 million
[Music]
4,000,000
5,000,000
Another furniture man Nene Sir
[Music]
Isn't there 7 million yen?
700 is 1.5 million.
It's exceeded. It's
profitable enough. Since ancient times, it's
just burning the village with no management expenses.
That child, Uetama, I want to buy it, so I
wouldn't know if I dropped it at a low price.
If you want to do it, you have to keep it clean,
because it's a girl, isn't it? It
's about time for the
7th voice.
Kinme is in a great
health condition
No trauma and no worm teeth
Start from 10 million
These are the targets of this time, so
I feel like 100 people
How many girls have made me cry so far
I went to Heisei
first  I'm prepared to not forgive the employees
, so I'll see again before [Music] nao Is there anyone who was reluctantly down to the yellow command that I could endure in this?
Ah ah ah
[Music]
Run away ran
me al Money etc. is red for the first time
[Music]
web
is always about town voodoo
Car
and lend me the time to
sing.
Ah ah ah ah
ah ah 9 ar
ame
[music]
And the tart is 5 standing
Rooney-san
After all, thank you for the black of the Duke of Ride.
I
can't forgive other aristocrats by attacking the village and kidnapping the girl under the guise of three born legs.
The infiltration investigation of Leah and Tart was the correct answer.
It
's not desirable to have more casualties in the meantime, it's been a long time to grab it
. It's too much to attack a neighboring village.
Bandit miners and trafficking are
felony.
Turnet Confirmation
5 Eliminate the Duke of Ride and those involved in the sale
based on the trust of the big mate assassin aristocrat Wahaha.